now uh i guess what we could do is we
could say
um dot dot dot depending on the question
because we've got three
terms if we establish a pattern i could
go to a general term
a n and just have like however many
there are but in fact you and me we're
trying to get to something specific
we're trying to get to uh this one here
yes
so let's just let's just go to a6 this
question doesn't require us to get a
general term
so a6 will equal okay now
what should be there we're trying to use
this follow the pattern i'll give you a
clue
it starts with a dollar what comes next
[Music]
nice okay so just in case we're you know
not following along here right
there's the initial dollar the very
first dollar we put in there it's got
this amount of interest on it
how many lots of interest and the answer
is
in this setup because it's at the end of
the year that we put the installment
it's always
one less than the number of years you've
been in there
one less than the number of years you've
been in there you're following how i'm
getting that from the pattern so that's
why this is one less
than the six and then we get the same
terms just it goes down
one uh index at a time so here comes
this guy here that's the second
installment was in there for the second
longest amount of time
three terms establishes my pattern so
dot dot dot what will be the last term
always a dollar right because that's
always happening at the end of the year
well done now at this point i mean it's
a sufficiently short series if you
wanted
you could just go to your calculator and
just chuck it all in okay but we don't
need to do that
we can take this whole thing and we can
pop it into
a formula that will do all of that
number crunching for us right
this in fact is a gp right this is what
we're searching for
i need the three characteristics um to
put this into the formula what are the
three
things i'm searching for tell me what
the terms are and then we'll get what
the values are so first i
need uh an a which is um my first term
right i need the next thing which is r
which is a
common ratio between and lastly a number
of terms
right how how long is this uh series
okay so now let's have a go at each one
first term what would you like to call
the first term
now instinctively you'd say oh the first
term is the first one here but well
actually it's easier we've seen this
before if we reverse the order
consider it from here and then it gets
bigger as you go to the left so i'm
going to call that guy
a yeah that enables me to say
from going from this end that way my
terms get bigger and bigger and bigger
because my ratio is
1.04 right okay fantastic
and then lastly how many terms are there
in this thing
there's the six right uh five four three
two one and then
zero so therefore six in total and i can
take all those three pieces
a iron and pop them into my some of the
gp formula so
a six equals can we do it from memory do
you need the reference sheet
what do you think okay good we start
with a which in this case is a dollar
right and then up in the brackets here
this this is a fraction do you remember
what's in here it's 1 to the power of
n uh so there's two different forms
right it's two different forms there's
an r minus one form and then there's a
one minus
r form which one is this one and then
there's
this one which one sorry that's really
messy which one's easier to use in this
case
yeah it's gonna be this one yeah why is
that
yeah i'm trying to avoid negatives my r
is bigger than one
so i'll use this one okay so therefore
i've got r
there it is to the power of
uh n which in this case is six so i
didn't leave myself enough space
there's out of the end take away one and
then what's on the bottom
let's go right yeah um 0.04 is what
you'll get but let's just write in this
step
question do you have a question
yeah no yeah are you a good assistant
yeah
um do we need to keep that double sign
in there at all times this guy here okay
do we need to get the dollar sign in
there at all times short answer is
no um you you're at the end of this say
this is
this is currency this is money so you're
going to conclude and say this is some
number of dollars
i'm putting in there for one simple
reason which is when you come back to
this this working in some number of
weeks or months time
right and there's a danger that if for
example i wrote it like this
right i've just taken off all the dollar
signs okay this will still give me the
correct
number okay however at least this is the
way my brain works
i just forget the meaning of stuff after
i've written it down in working like
like 10 minutes past i'm like who wrote
this who did this right
i'm putting a dollar here to remind
myself
where did that come from and the answer
is it came from the installments
right it's not just a number it actually
signifies um the annuity that's going in
does that make sense so it's totally
fine if you don't include the dollar
sign but
i mean it saves me the fact that i'm
going to have dollars at the end anyway
so i've got it all the way through as
well
has anyone while of installing gone to
the calculator and evaluated this
and i'd love to get a few decimal places
on this one please pam what do you got
for me
really did everyone get the same thing
six point six
yes three two
oh that's right nine seven five is that
all you got
four six two thank you sorry i know i
was misremembering a different decimal
place okay let's have a look at this guy
right does this line up with what we're
expecting
this whole table is to four decimal
places so when i round off
this guy's fine this guy's fine this guy
right
gets interacted with this guy right
because you're like that nine gets
rounded up from the seven after it
so it gets rounded up to ten carry the
one
and that's why you get six point six
three
three zero to four decimal places
as we were hoping make sense
63 cents oh you're talking about like to
lots of five
that's a really good question and i'm
going to tell you why we don't
uh do you see where it's going okay so
the question was why don't this is a
number of dollars right in fact i
silly left off the door sign and there's
a number of dollars why do we not do the
same thing we
do with all other currencies and just
round up to two decimal places what's up
with the four
okay well i couldn't have asked for a
better segue to this question here
how do we use these tables okay so this
is for an annuity over a grand total of
a dollar okay clearly annuities are
usually more than that okay
so as an example suppose i said
four percent per annum
uh six years but who
puts in a dollar every single year we're
going to have much larger sums let's say
for example it was
seven thousand dollars okay that's
actually quite reasonable for someone
putting into their superannuation fund
well how do i use all the stuff that i
just worked out the whole point of a
table is that we do not need to prove
this every single time
okay if i've got seven thousand dollars
then each individual dollar is going to
turn into
six point six three three zero dollars
so if you got seven thousand of them
from the table
right i would say uh total
well actually i don't need to say total
i can say future value that is what
we're determining right
future value equals 7 000
of those does that make sense because
each individual dollar is earning its
interest and all that kind of thing
so now hopefully you're seeing why six
three three zero
why we do not round that to six point
six five can someone tell me
it would happen it would make a big
difference wouldn't it
right these four decimal places are
there to cover the fact that we're very
likely going to multiply this by large
numbers
so if we introduce some error here by
approximation
i mean we're always introducing some
error but if it's a big error it's going
to become massive by the time we finish
what is this equal by the way
46 0004
431 i'll i'll take that nearest
one dollar
okay there you go actually it shouldn't
surprise us that that's exactly right
because
you've got four decimal places here the
fourth one ends up being zero so it's
almost as though it's not a significant
figure
and then you're multiplying by something
with three decimal places so that's why
it all sort of comes out in the wash
okay so future value tables
there you go that's where they come from
how you use them if they get handed to
you
is just by taking whatever the total
installment is and multiplying by the
appropriate row and column
okay let me just put two final notes
before i let you go further into this
document and just have it got some
exercises
number one this is the future value
table what's the opposite of a future
value
present value so there are also present
value tables
okay so we'll show you them later the
second thing to be cautious of is this
guy
and i put it in red so it would
highlight it right at the end
installments happen
when end of year for this question
for this table if i did installments at
the start of the year
this would be all different wouldn't it
i'll just give you
a quick example have a look right at the
top left hand corner just have a look at
it for the sake of
illustration a dollar one percent what
happens to that one dollar at the end of
one year
what does it say hold on hold on just
the first row one dollar one year
oh really look at it again
nothing's changed why is that and the
answer is because it happened at the end
of the year didn't have any time to earn
interest
if i change this to the start of the
year this table's all wrong or should i
say
this is not the table for that it should
be 1.01
now it's not just a change have a look
closely where is 1.01
on this table the answer is it's not
there
look again right because it's set up for
a whole different method or timing i
should say
of investment okay so you must be
careful you must be cautious
read this closely and then interpret the
table
accordingly okay to increase the
language yeah
language so uh
an interesting question for you to
answer so for those of you who didn't
get it right at the start
um if you go to canvas head to financial
mathematics 2
this document that we were mostly
looking at is the future values table
okay have a go download it and um
there's an exercise on the second page
[Music]
oh my goodness it's okay
how did we do